hey guys this is dennis the founder
thing here oh and i'm david griffin your
resident comic book and video game guru
and this is our review of the walking
dead season 4 episode 10 inmates yes so
last week was like the mid-season
premiere huh and you and me like kind of
had like good and bad things to say
about it like half of it we like the
other half we haven't yeah this episode
for me was a much bigger improvement I
like this a lot more than it's not
amazing or anything but I thought it was
solid and I liked what was going on how
about you I like the first half of it
which i would like to title is who's yo
daddy we got to see some the men you
know try to have father roles in this
one you know Tyrese a little more
literal than maybe Darrell's I like the
first half I want to praise the
direction of this big names Tricia Brock
directed The Killing episode Breaking
Bad HBO's girls i like the the opening
sequence with Beth and the narration you
know her talking over and voice over and
I thought that was really beautifully
shot I thought that was probably the
highlight for me of the episode i think
the strongest parts for me were in the
first half with tyrese in the girls and
with Daryl and Beth those are my
favorite parts of the episode I think I
liked it most of it just because these
are characters that I they care about
mmm at least most of them you know Dan
you got Darrell Maggie Glenn and yes the
the beginning part with with the
narration it's basically a voiceover of
best diary yeah her diary talking to her
mom I'm assuming to talk about leaving
the farm and all that I guess I haven't
talked to in a while i'm guessing mom
maybe maybe our journal maybe is writing
to all right to Julia hello journal yes
sir I forget what the oh yeah right so
yeah so I like that cuz it was like a
contrast to you know what was good
actually going on in and I I like her
reactions you know because she's she's
still optimistic know yet at the same
time she's still upset I mean she you
know saw her father get his head right I
mean Darrell even said he's like well
faith hasn't really done much for
especially your daddy and he was like
Google function is something yeah it's
like he wanted to say sorry everybody
didn't write
yeah but but I like her react you know
versus you know bring it back to last
week with Carl's like I feel like you
know he should have had more of a
sadness and and even the anger is fine
but why you no not towards his father
but just angry in general of what's been
going down you know why is life done
this and he have Beth here trying to
look as optimistic as possible even
though deep down she's very upset and I
think this is why it was the most
interesting part of the episode for me
because again and maybe I'm so hung up
on aisle of the video game series so
much and when I saw her and Daryl even
though she's older I kind of thought
about Clementine and Leo I know you play
at least the beginning part you know you
know Lee and Clementine and I I was like
man I wouldn't mind just like last the
last half of the four this season right
now in the governor little blonde girl
I'm like I could just watch them walk
around the country having the adventures
of Daryl and Beth I'm down to watch I
think but this the rest of the show I'm
just not that into you but I did like
Daryl and Beth like that's kind of a
cool combination i would like to see
them kind of off on their own together
more i think that's why i probably is my
favorite half in the episode was with
them and then you we had Tyrese with the
baby Judith I mean losing these two I
don't know I'm not for killing kids but
man Lizzie you can't be she almost
killed a baby yeah I mean there's
something wrong with her she was like
there's see I don't want to spoil
anything ok well there's a scene and now
this is I won't there's a scene in the
comic books now these characters don't
exist member the the twins the the boys
in the combo don't even don't even in
the story's not a spoiler but there's a
they do some weird things with an animal
like she was doing with the rabbits and
I think maybe they're kind of playing
off of that because she's getting a
little crazy she's weird I'm she's like
don't know what she's doing those rabbit
she's like torturing them I was just
trying to kill her what she was doing
she's weird yeah but I mean we see that
baby Judith is ya allah big she's
getting bigger and they did the whole
like what like reveal with tyrese like
Turner first of all they had the key
look flooded carry the baby we with the
two girls crying and walking even know
they were with anyone I don't know like
I was like
are they alone by themselves because
right there's no way they're gonna
survive right right yeah but there were
Tyrese and then they the big thing was
that carols back I don't ya I don't know
about the believability of Carol
actually finding them but ok right yeah
axes back and the whole thing is that
Tyrese doesn't know yeah that carol was
the one who killed his girlfriend right
who's all happy to see her embracing her
you know he was it was happy to see her
so she and she had assumed that Rick had
already told she seems surprised by his
warm embrace he was like he wasn't sure
cuz ya know that was enough time but
Rick had only had enough time to tell
Daryl before the right hurricane they
had to go upstairs exact right so we're
see The Adventures of the those guys
soon and they are heading towards
somewhere on the railroad track yeah so
though as i see it was I seeing Tyrese
being a badass Tyrese is the man I loved
him in the comics and you know it was
great to see him you know take control
and just beat all those walkers I like
Tyrese he's a good actor too and then
there's this I guess a sanctuary place
that's on that maps okay if you come
here you'll live but we can be safe we
can make it work here every arc in
Walking Dead has a point where they come
into a place that think they can make it
work in typical walking in that fashion
it's probably not going to work out
that's not a spoiler weaknesses subh
that's probably not gonna work out now
or it'll be boring we're with the show
going right you can't do that okay and
then on to Maggie who's separated from
Glenn she's with Sasha tyreese's sister
yep and Bob who we were talking about
earlier he doesn't look like a bob no
he's not a bob Thank that actor he was
in the wire his name was DeAngelo ya
know and now he's Bob Bob he's just
regular Bob regularly regular every man
Bob so Sasha Maggie and Bob had this
brilliant idea hey there's a bus full of
zombies are old bus of course let's see
if Glenn's and let's open that up and
see what happens of course before that
sequence even happens you know something
Bad's oh well you know that one at a
time is not really gonna that what does
yeah I mean nothing ever works out the
way it should but luckily you know
Glenn's not in there that was a scene
that I think if we hadn't seen the
preview yeah we were probably felt more
tension but I haven't seen the preview
last week we
solid Glenn was a lot bright yeah so
this scene was less impactful or this
sequence was less impactful because
they're right I didn't have that uh
tension of is Glenn a zombie or not
right because I knew he wasn't and I
don't mean to i don't know i'm getting a
little bit tired of seeing this whole
idea every time somebody's really upset
and they're bothered by something a lot
of you know and these people are going
through a tough time like something up
somebody call us out and last review
saying well Dennis and Dave if you were
going through the zombie apocalypse I
can see what you would do and it's like
well first of all is probably not going
to happen but uh probably not gonna a
driveway um but it's like everybody
comes to a point they get like this
milik they start like just killing
something aggressively like over and
over and smashed it over then they just
like stop sir I'm just getting a little
bit tired of seeing that it's like ok
get your mad get your upset I love Glenn
so I wanted to find glad I want him to
be together they're a good couple but
just seeing like somebody's bash I
looked to twice in this episode the girl
from the governor's camp yeah who Glenn
picked up she had a scene where Hugh
start just bashing somebody's head just
like getting all emotional letting all
over anger out I get it but that scene I
don't know how many times more I really
want to see a scene like that it's that
doesn't do anything for me emotionally
ok so on to Glenn yes line uh you know
he's by himself yeah he kind of is in
the worst place but has has I guess the
most in the sense of he's still in the
prison with all that stuff so he went
through all everywhere yeah belonging
including his own got the right gear got
you know food water lighter like just
all the supplies he could because he
knew no one was coming back so he's took
everything he could but he was in a
worse position cuz he was actually
surrounded by tons of them yeah yeah
versus the other people were in the
woods they're running to random ones
right everything blends winds a badass
and I had to here to get out of there
and he finds a girl just you know tora
tora is still a governor governor who
had a very deep romance with another
beautiful woman of course oh um no I
mean I like that I like I mean Glenn's
he's a good character I like him I like
you know the emotion the scene where she
was talking to him about like you know
why would you even want me yeah and he's
like I don't want you but I need you you
know I really like that that was those a
good scene also Glen's a good guy and I
think even if he didn't need her he
would have only guy couldn't just like
shot like yeah your specials death boom
I mean he wouldn't do that to me I think
you got along anyways unless she had
like unless he had seen her do something
horrific but he she was a bystander but
she didn't really kill him and also she
didn't fire a single shot out of her gun
no she was scared she got scared but you
know and then when you're talking about
earlier then she kind of went kind of
crazy at the end right blend passes out
and then at the very end we see the
three people that we don't know they
seem like military get what he say he
was like sorry sergeant Abraham yeah and
well I guess I don't spoil anything so
but yeah this is our characters from the
comic books so we're getting this whole
new team once the scientist wants a
sergeant and then the girl i'm
speculating that like okay these guys
are from this sanctuary place and and
then this sanctuary and i haven't read
the comic books past the prison so this
is not spoilers right i'm assuming that
somehow each group of people are gonna
end up in sanctuary and that's how
they're all going to reconnect that's
just my guess i won't comment on it
because but and also to I don't know
they gonna change it they've changed a
lot right there's certain characters
that lived and died that they changed
and the actors playing Abraham's you
know forget his name he's in band of
brothers Southland is really good actor
so I was happy to see that guy playing
Abraham such a good actor so I'm looking
forward to seeing that one thing i want
to say but you know before we wrap up is
I actually really liked how they kept
each story line separate instead of
weaving them together there's four
different groups right yeah there's no
like cutting back and forth and I think
it worked more effectively that way
because you the four groups are
separated and and when you edit think we
need interweave things you make them
seem like they're together see the
subconscious thing even though you know
they're not together when you start
editing between different places you you
get the feeling or connection that
they're together right in fact they are
separate so keeping them separate made
it feel like they were actually a
part right i mean like i said i just
because I didn't like the second half of
the episode as much I still love the
direction i mean i think the church
Brock did a great job directing this
episode it was a well shot episode I
really appreciate the direction of this
yeah for sure well I I liked this
episode especially on the heels of last
week so uh yeah let us know what you
think you can post your constable on the
website think here or calm or on our
YouTube channel think hear a pro make
sure to subscribe to that doesn't come
check us out on twitter if when I talk
to Dennis and myself about walking dead
why you love it why you know you know if
you're kind of so-so on the fence as I
am but you let us know you're reading
the comics are you playing tell tales
wonderful video game featuring
Clementine I let us know at think hero
i'm at griffin de we also the facebook
page that's facebook.com slash think
carroll fans make sure you like that
page and share our videos on facebook
and twitter and other social media will
really help us out thanks
you